U Une semaine après la visite
dede Nancy Pelosi à Taïwan,
lala Chine annonce qu'elle met n
àà ses manoeuvres militaires,
mamais qu'elle continuera
dede patrouiller régulièrement
lala région du détroit de Taïwa.
LeLe point sur la situation
avavec Benoit Hardy Chartrand,
chchercheur associé à la Chaire
RaRaoul-DaDandurand et professer
auauxiliaire à l'Université Teme
àà Tokyo.
BoBonjour merci d'être avec nou.
- - Bonjour.
- - Il y a clairement eu une
esescalade des tensions entre la
ChChine et Taïwan et avec ce que
vivient de lancer la Chine, il y
a-a-t-il toujours un risque
d'd'invasion à l'heure actuelle?
- - Évidemment que le risque est
totoujours là et c'est ce que
PéPékin veut faire savoir. Encoe
auaujourd'hui le bureau de
l'l'affaire taïwanaise qui est e
agagence du gouvernement chinoi,
cecette agence là où ce bureau a
rarappelé que la Chine était pre
àà tout pour utiliser la force
popour récupérer Taïwan. C'est n
memessage qu'ils veulent envoyeà
TaTaïwan qui n'est pas nouveauxt
quque ça fait déjà plusieurs
anannées que la pression augmen.
JeJe ne crois pas qu'une invasin
esest imminente mais compte tene
dedes tensions qui existent
acactuellement et des capacités
mimilitaires très importants dea
ChChine c'est une éventualité à
lalaquelle tout le monde doit êe
prprêt.
- - La Chine qui a publié
auaujourd'hui son livre blanc vs
lala réunification avec Taïwan
ququ'est-ce que vous en retenez?
- - C'est un document qui est
pupublié assez régulièrement par
lala Chine et des gouvernements.
C'C'est une marche à suivre pour
dodonner une idée des plans et s
ststratégies. Encens dans les
dodocuments qu'il y a de la
papatience par rapport à tout ce
ququi se passe à Taïwan, une
imimpatience par rapport à la
poposition américaine parce qu'n
lele considère comme ceux qui ft
auaugmenter la tension dans la
rérégion. On projette le blâme r
leles États-Unis pour la crise
dadans laquelle on se retrouve.
- - Oui les enseignements
amaméricains qui affirme qu'il y
auaura pas d'invasion avant deux
anans qu'est-ce qui peut être ft
d'd'ici là pour trouver un terrn
d'd'entente?
- - Je vous dirais que c'est
exextrêmement difficile parce qe
leles positions des deux camps
prprincipaux sont
irirréconciliables. Pour Taïwan
unune réunification et est
popossiblement envisagé pour le
gogouvernement et pour la
popopulation, impossible...
unune grande majorité de la
popopulation de 90 % qui ne
dédésirent pas une réunification
avavec la Chine. Alors que poura
ChChine s'une idée qui fait
coconsensus dans la population t
auau sein du gouvernement qu'on
dodoit éventuellement traîner
TaTaïwan. Tout ce qui peut être
fafait pour l'instant et peut-êe
dede s'asseoir entre les deux
paparties pour créer un lien et
alaller de l'avant parce que
ofofficiellement les positions
sosont beaucoup trop éloignées
popour qu'on puisse les rejoinde
unun jour.
- - Oui c'est tensions en même
tetemps ont des conséquences la
ChChine s'est retirée des
nénégociations avec les
chchangements climatiques avec s
EÉtats-Unis. C'est majeur est-ce
quque c'est inquiétant pour vou?
- - Oui ça m'inquiète déjà depus
plplusieurs années mêmes avant a
crcrise actuelle avec Taïwan. Le
lilien avait beaucoup décliné
enentre la Chine et les États-
UnUnis. Ça avait commencé lorsqe
TrTrump avait été élu. On avait
paparlé de la suspension sur les
chchangements climatiques et tos
leles problèmes sur lesquels ils
onont cessé de parler ça à touts
sosortes de conséquences sur le
mumultilatéralisme...
- - quel pourrait être le rôle u
CaCanada dans tout ça?
- - Ça fait quelques années quee
CaCanada veut jouer un rôle plus
imimportant en Asie. Ça remonteu
gogouvernement Harper. On sait e
l'l'Asie est une région qui
dedevient de plus en plus
imimportante. Le Canada a des
rerelations assez bonnes avec
cecertains partenaires dans la
rérégion dont le Japon, mais les
rerelations entre le Canada et a
ChChine ne sont pas très bonnesà
l'l'heure actuelle depuis déjà
dedeux années. Savants le rôle u
CaCanada plus effacé et sa tâche
plplus difficile pour avoir un
imimpact positif sur cette cris.
- - On va évidemment continuer e
susuivre ce qui se passe de prèà
TaTaïwan et en Chine.
PrProf